[Musique]
les capétiens qui se succèdent sur le
trône de france depuis 1987 anticipe le
sacre de leur fils aîné afin d'assurer
leur succession
le sacre distingue le capétiens de tous
les autres grands seigneurs quand bien
même l'un d'eux ou ray en territoire
plus important que le domaine royal
mais surtout légitime l'intronisation à
la faisant correspondre à la
concrétisation du projet divin
[Musique]
depuis le partage de l'empiré de
charlemagne la puissance publique ne
cesse de s'émietter en france une
multitude de petits seigneurs contrôle
d'un film territoire affaiblissant
l'autorité centrale
certains grands féodaux arrive à
canaliser ses forces centrifuges
menaçant le pouvoir du cap-haitien alors
plus symbolique que réelle
mais la logique de la pyramide féodal
donne la possibilité au roi des francs
de fiefs en fief de grands vassaux
engrand vassaux de faire remonter la
réalité du pouvoir jusqu'à lui
deux événements majeurs dans la deuxième
moitié du 11e siècle change la donne
première croisade voit de grands féodaux
français créé des états latins en terre
sainte et en 1066 le duc de normandie
guillaume le conquérant qu'on va y
l'angleterre et des places du même coup
outre-manche la pyramide féodal en cours
d'élaboration
1066 et guillaume le duc de normandie
guillaume le bâtard qui réussit la
conquête de l'angleterre et qui se fait
couronner roi d'angleterre à westminster
le 25 décembre 2000 66 alors pourquoi
est ce que c'est important parce que les
héritiers de guillaume vont s'associer
au fameux plantagenet et il va s'en
suivre des dizaines et des dizaines
d'années de guerre de succession
d'angleterre de province française etc
etc
cet événement est à l'origine de de
guerre de cent ans dont la première
débute au milieu du 12e siècle et dont
les héros s'appellent aliénor
d'aquitaine
luis est le pieux henri ii plantagenêt
richard coeur de lion et philippe ii de
france dit philippe auguste
associé au trône des 11 101 lorraine de
louis 6 legros ne débute vraiment quand
11 108 à la mort de son père philippe
premier s'il est vrai qu'il est
batailleur et que l'épée à la main ils
occupent la plus grande partie de son
règne en chevaux ses incessantes il en
est pas moins clairvoyant
tout d'abord la mise au pas de tous les
hors la loi est essentielle son peuple a
besoin de sa protection
le sacre l'y engagent
ensuite parce qu'il s'appuie sur un
conseiller prudent et habile
l'abbé de saint denis sujet
l'image de louis 6 véhiculées par ces
actions de pacification et par le sens
de la diplomatie de l'abbé sujet lui
permet aux 124 de résister une coalition
anglo germanique tous ses vassaux se
mobilisent pour sauvegarder le pouvoir
du roi
[Musique]
le duc de bourgogne le comte de
champagne le comte de flandre le comte
d'anjou le duc de bretagne le duc
d'aquitaine
répondant à l'appel du capétiens et cela
pour la première fois depuis l'avènement
de la dynastie
[Musique]
c'est vers le duché d'aquitaine et plus
particulièrement l'héritière la plus
puissante d'europe que se tourne louis 6
à la fin de son règne
en effet le duc d'aquitaine est mort
sans héritier mâle toujours animé par la
clairvoyance de l'abbé sujet le roi de
france celle pour plus de 100 ans le
destin de son royaume
en mariant son fils aîné aliénor 25
juillet 11 137 la petite aliénor
d'aquitaine et la fille de guillaume 10
duc d'aquitaine et guillaume duc
d'aquitaine dont elle est née à
châtellerault elle et guillaume lui va
avoir l'idée saugrenue de mourir en
partant pèlerinage à saint jacques de
compostelle un vendredi saint qui plus
est à 38 ans il va laisser il va laisser
le duché d'aquitaine à la petite aliénor
qu'il aimait tant parce qu'il n'ya pas
de loi salique en aquitaine là ça n'est
pas comme chez les francs saliens où
c'est l'homme qui hérite elle hérite le
duché d'aquitaine
elle n'a encore que 13 ans et devient
reine de france à la mort de louis 6 le
1er août
we7 n'était pas destiné à régner la mort
de son frère aîné six ans plus tôt la
sortie du cloître notre dame où il a été
élevé
il en gardera le surnom de luis est le
pieux ainsi qu'un état d'esprit tourné
vers la sobriété elle elle est la petite
fille de guillaume neuf hommes de
culture plutôt comme politique premier
troubadour de l'histoire a prôné une
nouvelle forme de relation amoureuse
l'amour courtois
guillaume ne considère pas la femme
uniquement sous l'angle de la
procréation d'une dynastie ou d'une
espèce ou l'église la cantonne trop
souvent il voit en elle un être humain
libre de ses actes dont il faut gagner
l'amour qui n'est plus uniquement un
devoir conjugal
au contraire cet amour ne peut se vivre
qu'en dehors des liens sacrés du mariage
mais quand il est obtenu en respectant
les règles de la courtoisie le
prétendant accède à la joie bien entendu
mais aussi au salut de tradition orale
la vieille histoire de tristan et iseult
va bientôt rentrer en littérature
l'histoire d'un amour pur celui d'un
chevalier pour sa reine que même la mort
ne pourra séparer c'est pourtant en
étant lié par le mariage que louis m
aliénor d'une façon immodéré en
particulier pour les membres de son
entourage laïque auclair qui voit dans
cet amour là faiblesse d'adam pour eve
[Musique]
dans le cadre de ce mariage éminemment
politique s'opère alors un choc des
cultures languedoc et langue d'oil celle
de la france du nord centralisé autour
de saint denis et de reims une culture
imprégnée de religiosité et d'austérité
et celle de la france du sud libéral et
enthousiaste le domaine royal a presque
triplé mais il ya des contradictions a
levé et des passions à canaliser
mais c'est bien avant l'arrivée
d'aliénor à paris que la cité avait été
au centre d'une polémique entre ces deux
visions du monde
la ville est déjà renommé pour son école
de théologie que pierre abélard a
participé à développer mais celui ci est
plus connu pour avoir vécu à la proche
de la quarantaine à partir de l'hiver 11
117 à 118 une passion dévastatrice pour
sa jeune élève de 17 ans héloïse et
abélard certains théologiens un
intellectuel c'est quelqu'un qui n'est
pas du tout attiré pas par la guerre qui
est né dans une famille aisée qui est
très porté vers l'étude vers les joies
de l'esprit les ont leur on le charge
des ducs est une jeune fille très
intelligente très très lettré et l'oithc
et la nièce du chanoine fulbert il ya
une véritable histoire d'amour qui se
passe entre évidemment l'oncle chanoine
n'apprécie pas du tout et ils veulent
rentrer alors précipitamment tous les
deux dans les ordres mais héloïse est
enceinte elle accouche d'un enfant
qu'elle appellera pierre astrolabe piqué
confiait denis elles sont ce pas très
bien ce qu'il est devenu
abélard afin de sauver l'honneur de la
famille d'eloïse fut sommé de l'épouser
mais cette héloïse qui s'y refusa
préférant abélard libre quand fermée
entre des liens matrimoniaux
le mariage du portant lieu tant les
pressions sociales était forte
cela ne suffit pas à l'oncle d'eloïse
qui retrouva son honneur en faisant
castres et abélard
des hommes demain de du chanoine fulbert
et masculin
un jour à bella pour lui faire payer le
le péché de chair est un acte absolument
barbares parce que il n'est pas du tout
accompagné de jugement en revanche les
deux les deux malfrats qui se sont
livrés à cette horrible besogne eux sont
jugés et on leur applique la loi du
talion c'est à dire qu'ils sont émasculé
aussi il ne reste alors à celui ci que
l'écriture pour vivre ces patients
sa vision du monde où chaque individu
pourrait avoir son mot à dire sur cette
terre heurte les sensibilités les plus
traditionalistes pour lesquelles
l'individu n'est rien face à la
collectivité
face à la chrétienté
[Musique]
la figure de proue de ce mouvement
conservateur et l'abbé de clairvaux
bernard de clairvaux va jouer un rôle
important dans les premières années du
mariage de louis et d'aliénor entre l'
influence de celle ci et les conseils
avisés de l'abbé sujet louis délaisse
progressivement la raison pour la
passion
pensant 41 son cousin raul de vermandois
alors âgé d'une cinquantaine d'années
s'éprend de pétronille la jeune soeur
d'aliénor à 15 ans raul n'est pas libre
et l'oncle de sa femme et le comte de
champagne petroni la petite soeur
d'aliénor d'aquitaine et elle est
follement amoureuse de raul de
vermandois et oui mais c'est un amour
impossible puisque raul vermandois est
déjà marié à elle et au nord de blois
bon elle va demander la petite
pétronille à la demande et aliénor sa
grande soeur et omar sy d'aliénor le roi
de france louis 7 de procéder à la
dissolution du mariage ce qu'ils vont
faire d'ailleurs et oui mais ça va
contrarier férocement la famille de raul
de vermandois et notamment son frère qui
va prendre les armes contre le roi de
france
le couple royal soutient l'annulation de
ce mariage afin que raul et pousse son
héloïse il persiste face au refus de
l'église et du pape et déclenche ainsi
un conflit avec la champagne
[Musique]
il faut l'intervention de bernard de
clairvaux 11 144 pour mettre fin à cette
crise
aliénor est marié depuis sept ans et n'a
pas d'enfants il semble que la pression
morale exercée par le moine associé à
langoat de la reine qui n'est pas encore
maire et poussé aliénor a fait reculer
louis sur la plupart des causes du
conflit
la paix revenue les relations avec la
papauté reprises aliénor met au monde
une petite marie
mais pour louis le pieux l'expiation des
fautes passe par une croisade
ce n'est encore que la seconde
elle est lancée officiellement par
bernard de clairvaux lors d'un prêche
enflammé avait gelé les turcs ont pris
possession d'un état latin aux mains des
chrétiens depuis 1098 la deuxième
croisade qui était organisé avec des
seigneurs des chefs de guerre des barons
qui on prend tirer les leçons de la
première croisade populaire qui n'a pas
été un grand succès et une croisade à la
fois militaire et religieuse et elle se
passe avec l'autorisation des autorités
religieuses un premier lieu du pape
c'est très important cette autorisation
du pape parce que il faut financer et
pour financer le pape fait quelque chose
d'assez exceptionnel c'est à dire qu'ils
l'autorisent à prélever l'impôt sur les
biens d'église
l'église ne payent pas d'impôts elle
elle en perçoit plutôt forme de dim
hélas il y a le des cimes qui est une
sorte d'impôt sur les revenus de tous
les biens d'église et qui permet
l'effort de guerre si l'on peut dire est
donc cette organisation des croisades
est à la fois religieuses militaires et
administratifs puisqu'il ya perception
de l'impôt aliénor décide d'accompagner
son époux
pendant ce temps raul et pétronille
continue à s'aimer en toute
clandestinité
[Musique]
la croisade qu'entreprennent aliénor et
louis va marquer un tournant dans leur
relation et dans l'histoire de france
c'est en terre sainte qu'au cours de
l'année 11 148 se produit une série
d'incidents alors louis cette part en
croisade
accompagné de son épouse allaient
aliénor la campagne en effet et sont
deux personnalités totalement différente
le syndicat thivel et lesperon télé
courageuse lui est un peu mou hésitant
un peu be good eye on le surnomme luis
est le pieux est bon ils traversent la
méditerranée et lui veut marcher vers
jérusalem à tout prix or on s'arrête à
antioch
le couple est hébergé par l'oncle
d'aliénor raymond jeune prince francs du
royaume d'antioche
après avoir séjourné à constantinople
une autre cour d'orient offre aliénor
une vision plus proche de ses idéaux que
celle de paris moins austère et plus
ambitieux aussi raymond compte sur
l'aide de louis pour regagner du terrain
face aux infidèles
échaudé par des déboires subis plus au
nord louis veut éviter l'affrontement
pour l'instant et donne la priorité à un
pèlerinage à jérusalem
les rumeurs et les railleries commence à
aller bon train quand on évoque le temps
que passent ensemble raymond et aliénor
le départ pour jérusalem est avancée
mais aliénor refuse de suivre louis
devant son assistance et le rappel des
devoirs d'une femme
aliénor demande l'annulation du mariage
pour cause de consanguinité menace
reposant effectivement sur des éléments
avérés dans les relations de la pyramide
féodal sont étroites
louis est tenté d'accepter par dignité
mais par stratégie politique
il suit les conseils de ses barons et
enlève aliénor afin de l'emmener avec
lui à jérusalem le pèlerinage est
effectué mais les tentatives de
reconquête en terre sainte ont échoué
le couple rentre de croisade dans deux
navires différents leur route passe par
rome où semble-t-il le pape réussi à les
réconcilier si réconciliation il ya eu
elle durera deux ans le temps d'un autre
enfant une fille encore alors au retour
des croisades ou bien le la situation du
ménage du couple louis 7 et aliénor
n'est pas vraiment idyllique parce que
on l'a vu elle est très contrarié par le
caractère un peu indolente son mari elle
reste en aquitaine et lui sommes tous
très bien s'il fait le bilan de cette
croisade c'est un bilan relativement
catastrophique il a perdu beaucoup
d'hommes financièrement c'est aussi
quelque chose qui lui a coûté très cher
sentiment tellement senti mentalement il
a perdu son épouse et territorialement
comme elles gardent l'aquitaine qui ne
veut pas lui donner
eh bien il n'a plus rien à gagner en
partant en croisade
louis avait laissé le champ libre à
l'ambition de jofra lebel comte d'anjou
profitant de la guerre entre les
prétendants au trône d'angleterre
geoffroy qui avait déposé la petite
fille de guillaume le conquérant avait
fait valoir ses droits sur le duché de
normandie
[Musique]
il y avait même investi son fils henry
sans l'accord de louis et donc en
enfreignant le droit féodal
c'est l'affrontement en 151 et bernard
de clairvaux intervient de douvres
un accord est trouvé henri 17 ans vient
à paris prêter hommage à son roi être
confirmée ducs de normandie
le jeune homme robuste et de belle
allure porte une branche de genêt à son
chapeau et une nouvelle rumeur celle de
trop se met à courir qu'aliénor de dix
ans son aîné n'est pas insensible au
charme de celui qui allait devenir avec
elle le fondateur d'une dynastie
légendaire les plantagenêts en mars 11
152 louis répudier aliénor qui est
contrainte de laisser ses deux filles
sous la protection de leur père en mai
elle épouse en la cathédrale de poitiers
henri ii plantagenêt à eux deux ils
forment déjà un empire et henry n'a pas
encore fait valoir les droits de sa mère
au trône d'angleterre
ce sera chose faite en 11 154 geoffroy 5
lebel comte d'anjou va se marier avec
mathilde mathilde n'est autre que la
petite fille de guillaume le conquérant
la fille d'henri 1er tous les deux été
roi d'angleterre
un combat acharné va être menée en
angleterre entre mathilde et son cousin
etienne de blois c'est mathilde qui
finira par prendre l'aventage et
accédera au trône d'angleterre le fils
de mathilde et geoffroy henri
plantagenêt
le célèbre henri ii plantagenêt rien ne
semble arrêter le plantage les aliot
nord est donc une deuxième fois rennes
tandis que les naissances se succèdent
chez les plantagenêts le capi s'y attend
toujours un fils après la mort de sa
seconde épouse ans 160 en mettant au
monde sa quatrième fille louis se
remarie avec adèle de champagne ce qui
fait la force des plantagenêts cet
immense territoire et cette prodigieuse
descendance allait causer leur perte
l'apport de cette dot par aliénor
d'aquitaine sera très très important car
elle elle inversera le rapport de force
entre les deux souverains d'abord à la
faveur de luis est roi de france puis à
la faveur d'henri ii plantagenêt roi
d'angleterre le territoire qui
appartient au plantagenêt à cette époque
et est assez remarquable
il hérite par son père geoffroy 5 lebel
de la touraine de l'anjou et du maine
par sa mère mathilde et bien de la
bretagne et de la normandie par sa femme
aliénor d'aquitaine
alors là de la guyane dans l'aquitaine
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui de l'auvergne
de la gascogne du poitou également et
puis au final de l'angleterre dès son
couronnement
m
lorsqu'on lit de plantagenet est arrivé
à chinon il a trouvé une vieille
forteresse qui avait été construite par
les comptes de blois et ensuite amendé
par ses ancêtres les pompes d'anjou la
transformation importante qu'il a
effectuée à la forteresse de chillon
c'est la construction d'un palais 9 plus
commode pour loger son administration et
qui se trouvait sur le fort saint
georges
[Musique]
mais
dans un premier temps j'ai les capétiens
adele a d'abord une fille mais une
deuxième grossesse suis louis voit alors
en rêve le fils tant attendu il tient un
calice rempli de sens qu'il donne à
boire aux grands du royaume
le miracle a bien lieu louis a enfin un
fils le 21 août 11 165 qu'il prénomme
philippe et que l'on surnomme dieudonné
à l'est le champagne est une femme
fréquemment mallard d'assez malingre et
il n'a pu n'arrive pas à avoir un
héritier avec elle il est désespérée
puisque au bout de 30 ans de vie commune
on n'a toujours pas vu le son épouse
portait un fruit or ce fruit se profile
à l'horizon
et comme ce fruit va voir le jour de
façon fantastique on va au bout de 30
ans mais c'est un don de dieu et c'est
pour ça qu'on l'a surnommée philippe
auguste mais philippe dieudonné auguste
c'est les plantagenêts richard a alors
huit ans un dernier fils né en 1967 il
est prénommé jean
[Musique]
les fils d'aliénor grandissent et la
reine est une épouse délaissée henry
vivent une liaison adultère au grand
jour henri est alors puissant si
puissants qu'ils pensent pouvoir se
passer de l'aide de dieu et surtout du
pouvoir spirituel qu'il représente sur
terre si puissant qu'il ne consent cas
délégué de manière fictive le pouvoir à
ses fils si puissants qu'ils pensent
passer de l'aide d'ali nord aliénor
d'aquitaine c'était très mal entendu
avec son premier mari luis est le pieux
et bien elle épouse en riche en
deuxièmes noces et elle ne va pas sans
entendre davantage très longtemps avec
lui elle va lui faire une belle tribu
d'enfants 5,6 de fismes et a
partiellement où les enfants sont
devenus des adultes responsables et bien
et que son mari l'une pour un peu le
guide ou de droite et de gauche
eh bien elle va prendre une position
pour les enfants en 173 après avoir
obtenu l'alliance de son premier époux
aliénor et ses fils déclenché une
insurrection qui se propage dans tout
l'empiré la risle post d'henry et
foudroyante
il repousse les français il mate la
rébellion et tandis qu'il choisi de
pardonner à ses fils ils capturent
aliénor qui l'emprisonnent en angleterre
aliénor d'aquitaine avait soutenu la
révolte de ses fils contre leur père et
lorsqu'elle a cherché à s'enfuir à fuir
son mari henri ii plantagenêt
elle a été rattrapée par lui et il l'a
fait emprisonner à la forteresse de
chillon pendant plusieurs mois à partir
du mois de novembre 11 173 et elle y
restera jusqu'à son départ en angleterre
au mois de juillet 11 174 donc elle
repart en angleterre avec son mari henri
ii plantagenêt et après sa captivité de
quelques mois à chinon elle restera
enfermé en angleterre selon la volonté
de son mari dans la tour de salisbury
pendant près de 15 ans la pacification
de l'aquitaine est menée par richard
lui-même qui est pourtant à l'origine du
soulèvement
le troisième fils d'aliénor et gagne un
surnom coeur de lui en une prophétie
fait par merlin cinq siècles auparavant
inquiète pourtant henry elle évoque la
libération d'un aigle à deux têtes par
sa troisième niche
entre 11 164 et on 185 est écrit une
série d'ouvragés qui est considéré comme
la génèse de la littérature française
l'auteur s'appelle chrétiens et est
originaire de troyes il est le protégé
de la comtesse de champagne marie fille
aînée d'aliénor et de louis son oeuvre
s'articule essentiellement autour de la
légende d'arthur et des chevaliers de la
table ronde que chrétien va participer à
transformer en mythe l'influencent de
l'amour courtois en remontant vers le
nord
rencontre le modèle du roi chevalier et
chrétiens invente le roman de chevalerie
influencé par les aventures d'arthur et
de ses chevaliers les plantagenêts vont
influencer les romans des siècles à
venir
tout comme les capétiens se réclame
descendants de charlemagne les
plantagenêts se disent prolonger la
ligne et d'arthur chevalier aussi
méritent que lancelot du lac
richard punissez baron rebelles avec la
même brutalité que s'il s'agissait
d'envoyer de satan
pour fédérer le cap et si un peu lui
s'appuyer sur le sacre et louis
programme celui de son fils pour le 15
août 11 179 il faudra le différé en
chasse en forêt de compiègne le jeune
homme de 14 ans distance ses compagnons
et empreintes des sentiers obscur
hilaire pendant deux jours et deux nuits
quand on le retrouve il reste prostré et
muets entre la vie et la mort
louis désespéré fait la tournée des
sanctuaires pour obtenir son
rétablissement
il est finalement exaucé philippe est
sacré le jour de la toussaint et rien ne
pourra plus l'arrêter
on ne sait rien de plus de ces deux
nuits que philippe a passé seul dans la
forêt
l'épisode fini d'avoir raison de louis
il meurt le 18 septembre 11 181
c'est maintenant philippe qui jouent des
dissensions entre les quatre frères
plantagenêt et leur père dès sa première
entrevue avec le nouveau roi de france
vieux plantagenêt est impressionné par
sa prudence et son assurance qualité que
doit avoir un roi chevalier mais qu'il
ne retrouve pas chez ses fils
après la mort brutale de deux d'entre
eux richard n'a plus qu'un frère le
prince jean mais on apprend aux 187 une
terrible nouvelle venue d'orient le
sultan d'égypte saladin s'est emparé de
jérusalem alors que tous nos héros font
feu de croisade à l'exception de gens
pendant les préparatifs des combats
reprennent et la prophétie de merlin de
s'accomplir
philippe se rapproche de richard et
affronte avec lui le vieux roi henry
pour qui c'est la dernière bataille le
roi philippe auguste ne valent l'aider
dans sa lutte contre son père
favoriser l'accession donc au pouvoir
parce que philippe auguste et richard
était très lié très amis à l'origine ce
fameux traité d'azay-le-rideau et un
traité qui a précédé de quelques jours
la mort du roi henri ii plantagenêt
ils étaient pourchassés par le roi de
france et par ses fils notamment richard
coeur de lion qui ont dit que ce traité
d'azay-le-rideau et une pelleteuse pour
henri ii plantagenêt
par ce traité il prend connaissance
aussi de la trahison de son dernier fils
jean sans terre et il va reconnaître par
ce traité un certain nombre de
territoires au roi de france ainsi que
le mariage de son fils richard coeur de
lion avec la soeur du roi de france à
hélices vaincu henry se soumet pour la
première fois de son existence qui
s'achève
apprenant que même jean a participé à le
trahir il meurt seul de 6 juillet 11 189
henri ii plantagenêt
fini ces derniers jours abandonnée de sa
famille et de ses enfants dont kg il
vient jusqu'à chinon où il va passer ces
derniers jours et
mucha seule et abandonnée de tous
[Musique]
aliénor est libre richard et roanne
angleterre est interdit à son frère jean
d'y séjourner jusqu'à son retour de
croisade
felli prend aussi ses précautions et
lance la construction de l'enceinte du
louvre
il rédige un testament ou est définie
pour la première fois la fonction
monarchique comme une fonction d'état
c'est-à-dire oeuvrant pour le bien
public
il délègue ses pouvoirs non pas des
grands du royaume mais à des
représentants de l'état eux même
contrôlé par un conseil de notables
c'est cette organisation qui finira par
faire la différence
les deux rois richard et philippe parc
pour la troisième croisade ensemble le 4
juillet 11 190 avant de prendre deux
routes différentes qui les font se
retrouver en sicile en septembre où ils
attendent le printemps
richard dit à philippe auguste ce serait
bien que vous m'accompagner en réalité
il se méfie de philippe auguste il se
dit si je pars en croisade seul il va
risquer de récupérer mais territoire le
même l'anjou et la norme anti donc ils
partent en croisade et il arrive en
sicile où ils sont accueillis d'ailleurs
par des normands puisque la sicile est
un royaume normand fondé autrefois par
robert de l'iss car tancrède de
hauteville et là il tombe malade
quasiment en même temps l'un et l'autre
on souffre de ce qu'on appelle la suette
millière ils perdent leurs cheveux ils
perdent leurs ongles on perd philippe
perrin oeil même philippe auguste vers
hanoï et ensuite direction la terre
sainte
c'est richard mobiliser toutes les
ressources possibles pour faire de cette
croisade un succès cournède exploits de
chevalerie philippe est préoccupé parce
qu'il laisse derrière lui un royaume où
son autorité s'est renforcé et un fils
louis orphelin de mère à trois ans
les prouesses de richard aux combats
l'ont précédée en sicile et on attend de
lui qu'il règle un problème de
succession alors que philippe est
partisan de la négociation afin de
stabiliser la situation
richard en fait un problème personnel
qu'il faut régler avec panache il décide
de ramener l'ordre à sa manière en
mettant à sac mais s'il est surtout en
plantant sur les murailles de la ville
ces étendards à fierté du roi de france
et particulièrement éprouvées tandis que
philippe traverse directement la
méditerranée pour rejoindre saint jean
d'âcre richard passe par chypre ils
dépendants de l'empiré byzantin mais
dont le prince à la recherche
d'autonomie collabore avec salade à
l'occasion est belle pour richard
d'ajouter une ligne à la liste de ces
explora chypre est conquise il peut
maintenant rejoindre saint jean d'âcre
ou philippe peine à prendre la ville
avec richard la ville tombe
les deux bannières flotte cette fois-ci
ensemble le duc d'autriche veut aussi
planté son étendard richard lui refuse
ce droit est reine sa manière dans la
boue très rapidement on va voir que la
mésentente vint s'installer sur la terre
sainte entre richard et entre eux son
ami philippe auguste une amitié dont il
faut se méfier parce que philippe
auguste lui veut absolument combattre
saladin gagner saint jean d'âcre et
richard arrive en retard enfin on sent
que sylla et conquérant l'autre est
hésitant et philippe auguste va dire
dans ces conditions ça suffit je rentre
la prochaine étape et jérusalem
cela sera son philippe malades préoccupé
par les affaires de son royaume il
décide de rentrer en france dès 11 191
il s'arrête à rome pour obtenir du pape
l'absolution en disant voilà je quitte
la croisade ne m'en veuillez pas et
pendant ce temps là richard lui va
rester ce se battre parfois même comme
comme un soudard parce qu'on sait qu'ils
massacrent à tour de bras
il attend on lui a promis le vrai
couronne du christ et comme il ne
l'obtient pas eh bien ils massacrent les
prisonniers la reconquête de jérusalem
est hypothétique
et de toute façon la gloire en
reviendrait à richard à richard la
légende un philippe l'histoire
devant jérusalem richard sont les
troupes de philippe doit composer avec
sa lada le lieux saints restent aux
mains des musulmans mais les chrétiens
pourront s'y rend en pèlerinage
richard refuse de rentrer dans jérusalem
en pèlerin puisque il rêvait d'y rentrer
l'épée à la main en octobre 11 192 il
prend la mer une tempête l'obligent à
changer d'itinéraire
il doit traverser le duché d'autriche
leduc ne l'a pas oublié malgré son
déguisement richard a capturés et vendus
à l'empereur germanique que philippe a
eu tout loisir de rangées de son côté
maintenant que richard n'est plus
croisés mais toujours absent philippe
complote avec le prince jean qui se
proclame roi
le gens ne peut atteindre son nouveau
royaume
lille est défendu par les barons fidèles
à richard sette aliénor qui veille
11 193 philippe nani flotte ni femme en
épousant hing bourgue la soeur du roi du
danemark
ils comptent remédier à ces deux lacunes
la promise est parée de toutes les
vertus 18 ans belle intelligente pieuse
et quand il la rencontre philippe est
sous le charme
le mariage est célébré et le lendemain
de la nuit de noces à la stupéfaction
générale philippe demandes à la
délégation danoise de repartir avec
celle qui est pourtant reine de france
on ne sait rien de plus de cette nuit
que philippe a passé seul avec une
gueule burg
[Musique]
on raconte que sa nuit de noces a été
catastrophique puisque dès le lendemain
matin il a expédié au couvent à saint
maur des fossés et attentes et a essayé
de faire annuler son mariage
pourquoi l'admin noah était à qu'elle
était catastrophique
alors les historiens du temps les
chroniqueurs du temps nous raconte qu'il
avait pas ce qu'on appelle l'aiguillette
nous et c'est à dire qu' il n'avait pas
pu consommer ce mariage le projet d'un
débarquement en angleterre est repoussé
au bout de deux ans d'âpres négociations
ralenti par les interventions discrètes
de philippe afin de faire monter les
enchères
aliénor obtient en février 11 694 la
libération de richard déchaîné il l'est
dans tous les sens du terme
j'en demande immédiatement pardon et
fait massacrer la garde française
protégeant evreux en signe de repentance
sitôt débarqué en angleterre où il est
accueilli par les acclamations de la
foule qui chantent et dansent richard
punit les partisans de jean c'est le
lendemain de la prise de nottingham
qu'il découvre lors d'une partie de
chasse
la forêt de sherwood quand il est libéré
enfin grâce à la rançon versée par
aliénor d'aquitaine et bien richard
naturellement immédiatement constate que
le comportement
quel a été le comportement de son frère
jean sans terre john blake landes comme
on l'appelait à londres on voit tout ça
dont les fameux romande quentin durward
robin des bois bien s'aperçoit que il l'
a failli lui usurpé la couronne donc
évidemment il fallait punir il va le
l'emprisonner mais il lui pardonnera
très rapidement
mais les affaires l'appel sur le
continent le 12 mai 11 100 94
il quitte l'angleterre qu'il ne reverra
jamais le premier affrontement entre
richard et philippe a lieu entre
normandie et en joue à fréteval et voit
la déroute de l'armée française la perte
du trésor royal ainsi que de nombreux
documents indispensables à
l'organisation du royaume philippe
décide de mettre fin à cette tradition
d'une administration itinérante et fonde
la même année des archives royales qui
seront dorénavant conservés dans le dojo
du louvre il est le premier à
redécouvrir le rôle fondamental de
l'écrit dans la gestion d'un état afin
de mettre chacun devant ses
responsabilités pour asseoir son
autorité
richard préfère la pierre aux papiers et
érigeant vallée de seine afin de
protéger la normandie un château qu'il
veut imprenable château gaillard alors
philippe auguste n'a qu'une idée en tête
c'est récupérer la normandie donc il va
lancer quelques attaques sur la
frontière de de l'ile-de-france et de la
normandie
richard bien sûr voulant conserver ce
duché qui est quasiment une annexe de
l'angleterre va couvrir la frontière va
ceinture et la frontière de
fortifications que ce soit à verneuil à
ivry que ce soit à gisors et surtout et
surtout la clé de voûte de ses
fortifications c'est le fameux château
gaillard des andelys qu'il a construit
en un an de temps ce château a jailli de
la falaise en un an de temps le
constatant cette réalisation d'ailleurs
eu il aura cette expression merveilleuse
qu'elle est belle ma fille d'un an quel
château gaillard
et
m
comme leurs noms l'indiquent les
forteresses et les châteaux sont des
lieux fortifiée il était donc surtout
destiné à protéger et à maîtriser un
territoire
il y avait cette notion de maillage du
territoire ponctuée par par les châteaux
pour commander les territoires et on le
voit bien à chinon avec ce site de
hauteur qui est placé sur un éperon
rocheux qui lui permet de surveiller les
alentours et d'avoir une position
privilégiée
tout irait bien si richard honorer la
couche de sa femme
philippe lui est amoureux il épouser en
troisièmes noces agnès qui lui donne
deux enfants
richard n'aurai jamais d'enfants
légitime
il semble qu'il ait décidé d'assumer
dans la mesure du possible son
homosexualité ou bien croit-il qu'il a
le temps
[Musique]
son esprit chevaleresque le pousse à
défier la mort pendant les combats et
alors qu'il enchaîne les victoires en
normandie le destin le rappelle une
dernière fois en aquitaine où le vicomte
de limoges est passé du côté français
[Musique]
la place fort de loches est une des
propriétés de la couronne d'angleterre
c'est une prédominance vexante pour tous
les successeurs de louis 7 et des
philippe auguste donc le roi va va
tenter de reconquérir tout le territoire
richard coeur de lion accède au trône en
1989 mais il sera fait prisonnier à son
retour de croisade et philippe auguste
en profitera à ce moment là ont tout
début 1194 pour reprendre loches la
place-forte la forteresse richard une
fois libéré va revenir en france et le
13 juin de cette même année 1194 il va
reprendre loge dans ce qu on dit
aujourd'hui être un assaut irrésistible
de trois heures
[Musique]
richard surveille toutes ses possessions
et notamment on lui apprend que en
limousin dans la ville de chalut haute
vienne aujourd'hui est bien un de ces de
ses suzerains aurait découvert un trésor
est naturellement ce trésor lui revient
richard le lui fait savoir et le
suzerain lui ne veut pas du tout s'en
séparer s'en débarrasser halo reach
arval est assiégé la ville de saintes de
chalut en limousin c'est à l'occasion de
ce siège qu'un un tireur d'arbalète lui
décoche un carreau qu'il reçoit les
indices dans le dans l'euro dans le dans
les pôles les autres disent dans le
fondement mais georges est il que
l'infection se met dans la plaie elle va
mourir
richard coeur de lion sentant la mort
arriver richard demande sa mère à son
chevet qui arrive à temps son fils
expire dans ses bras de 6 avril en 199
on 199 12 cents à l'orée de ce 13e
siècle se prépare l'union du fils de
philippe auguste et de la petite fille
d'aliénor blanche de castille
la paix semble enfin revenu entre
capétiens et plantagenêt gens se
déclarent vassal de philippe qui a alors
une problématique d'un autre ordre à
résoudre en effet l'amour de philippe
pour agnès et jette l'interdît sur l'île
de france
après qu'un nouveau pape est jugé la
sphère ingeborg le pape n'a pas voulu
l'annuler ce mariage il va quand même
épousé une troisième épouse agnès de
mélanie tout en étant bigame il
s'habille gamme puisque le mal le
premier mariage n'est pas annulée alors
le le ca va avoir des conséquences
terribles pour le royaume de france car
le pape va frapper le royaume
d'interdits c'est à dire que à la suite
donc à cause de cette mine noces
malchanceuse eh bien on ne pouvait plus
célébrés de culte sur le territoire plus
aucun sacrement ne peut être célébré
nimetz ni baptême la société est
paralysé
si consciencieux dans la structuration
d'un état philipp lahm est en péril en
oubliant la raison il fait alors de
reprendre in gauburge comme épouse
légitime et obtient qu'agnès enceinte
accouche à poissy tourmenté agnès donne
vie à un petit tristan en hisser dans la
sienne
il ne lui survit que quelques heures la
haine de philippe pour ingo burg
n'atténue pas l'amour qu'elle lui porte
c'est un autre mariage qui va permettre
à philippe de revoir ses ambitions à la
hausse
celui de jean avec isabelle taillefer
comtesse d'angoulême
alors que celle ci était promise au
compte de la marche le rapt d'une
fiancée est un incident dans un monde
féodal qui mérite une compensation
or ce n'est pas dans les moeurs de gens
de respecter les règles
l'affairé portée devant la justice de
philippe comme le veut le droit féodal
quand il ya querelle entre deux assauts
jean est convoqué devant la cour de
france qu'il n'honore pas de sa présence
le roi d'angleterre est alors condamné
et se voit confisquer tous ces pièces de
france pour rupture du lien féodal en
202 il devient jean sans terre
c'est au tournant historique dans
l'utilisation de la logique de la
pyramide féodal seule la justice de dieu
est au dessus de celle du roi c'est
aussi une déclaration de guerre et j'en
ai pas richard faisant preuve de la même
patience et de la même lucidité que dans
la gestion de son royaume
pendant six mois philippe assiègent
château gaillard qui finit par céder en
12 104 la porte de la normandie est
grande ouverte et le capétiens prend
possession de tous les territoires des
plantagenêts au nord de la loire
[Musique]
jean sans terre avait fait un certain
nombre d'améliorations pour préparer la
forteresse à la guerre donc il a fait
venir à chinon dans ce but
l'un de ses ingénieurs qu'on appelait m
uri et qui était en fait un ingénieur
spécialisé dans les machines de g
puisqu'il faut savoir que la guerre au
xiième et xiiième siècle c'était avant
tout des guerres de siège et qu'on
utilisait énormément des machines de ge
est telle que les
iman gonnot les pires hier pour
endommager les remparts
[Musique]
le siège le plus important il aura lieu
en 1204 1205 un siège d'une année
entière et l'assaut final aura lieu au
mois d'avril
ce sont les troupes françaises avec à
leur tête philippe auguste qui
réussiront à reprendre définitivement
loge au plantagenêt à l'époque la del à
la forteresse était défendu par 120
hommes environ et jean sans terre perd
sa forteresse
le château de chinon et repris par le
roi de france philippe auguste au cours
d'un siège qui va durer neuf mois qui va
commencer à l'automne 12 104 et qui va
se terminer en juin 12 105 seul
l'aquitaine reste encore hors de
contrôle mais aliénor elle a tout donné
elle meurt à 80 cents quant à philippe
il lui reste une bataille pour qu'il
prenne le nom du premier césar et
deviennent philippe auguste
après avoir renversé le rapport de force
avec les plantagenêts l'ambition de
philippe fait peur
certains ont pris l'habitude de
l'autonomie et voit d'un mauvais oeil
les projets du capétiens faire respecter
la justice et le droit
créer un état monarchique et agrandir
son territoire
jusqu'où malgré les efforts de l'église
et d'hommes comme bernard de clairvaux
malgré les romans de chrétien de troyes
les grands du royaume n'agissent pas
tous en fonction du bien commun mais
bien par ambition
philippe avait fait en sorte que son ami
d'enfance
renault souhaite à la tête du comté de
boulogne fief stratégique
pourtant celui-ci se range aux côtés du
plantagenêt jean sans terre va aussi
pouvoir compter sur le nouvel empereur
germanique au thon 4 qui est son neveu
philippe auguste envisage maintenant
puisque il s'est emparé de la normandie
la normandie est devenue française en 12
104 l'année de la mort d'aliénor
d'aquitaine et il envisage même nom de
d'envahir l'angleterre comme l'avait
fait
guillaume le conquérant et jules césar
autrefois mais ça ne plaît pas
évidemment à la plupart des souverains
européens
il va y avoir une coalition contre
philippe auguste avec l'empereur
notamment l'empereur germanique avec
jean sans terre avec tel baron flamand
et tous ces gens là vont lever une armée
gigantesque
leur stratégie est de prendre l'armée
française en tenaille gens débarquent à
la rochelle et remonte vers le nord
tandis que des flandres laissant le
reste des effectifs coalisés
philippe envoie son fils louis à la
rencontre du roi d'angleterre qui
choisit la fuite
l'important était de disperser les
troupes royales l'armée de philippe est
composé de fidèles mais ils sont à 1
contre 3 alors que cette armée se
rapproche de bouvines le dimanche 27
juillet 12 114 la coalition impérial et
repérer mais une bataille n'est pas une
guerre
c'est un jugement de dieu et le
vainqueur et son élue elle ne peut avoir
lieu un dimanche la tension des derniers
jours est tellement palpable que
l'empereur décide de ne pas attendre et
philippe de ne pas refuser le combat
la bataille s'engage à midi au centre du
front le roi s'expose un coup mortel et
par et grâce au sacrifice d'un chevalier
le flanc gauche de l'empereur cède en
premier les français se regroupent alors
au centre haute on échappe à la capture
de justesse et réussit à fuir en
laissant savagnières à terre renault
reste deux derniers enchaînant sortie et
replie derrière ces piétons armée de
pique
il veut combattre jusqu'à la mort et son
cheval est abattu grâce à un noyau dur
de fidèles
la victoire du roi de france est totale
il est 5 heures de l'après midi
pr nomura 13 ans plus tard dans la
prison dans laquelle il fut jetée et le
lendemain de bouvines cette rencontre
rencontre absolument béni des dieux si
l'on peut dire puisque il va l'emporter
de haute lutte alors qu'il avait moins
de soldats que l'ennemi est
naturellement tout le monde va crier au
miracle
qui plus est cette bataille s'était
déroulé un dimanche donc on a dit que
c'était à la grâce de dieu qu'il l'avait
gagnée et cette bataille de bouvines
allait marquer véritablement le le bleu
le coup d'envoi du grand royaume de
france avec l'âme de la france béni dans
le sens de la bataille de bouvines
l'honneur de la chevalerie se retrouvent
autour d'un centre d'attraction le cas
des siens qui incarne une notion en
train de naître
la batterie ce n'est qu'après sa mort
que richard grâce au roman de chevalerie
exercera le même pouvoir en angleterre
philippe auguste est le dernier roi des
francs et le premier roi de france
sur bien des aspects ce n'est plus un
endroit médiévale mais un roi à modern
l'a fallu attendre des des travaux assez
poussées notamment au xxème siècle avec
un auteur l'historien américain baldwin
pour découvrir un peu la personnalité de
philippe auguste qui était quelqu'un de
2 da ses angoisses et d' assez émotif
ce qui ne l'a pas empêché d'être un
grand roi c'était une personnalité un
peu paradoxal c'est à dire c'est
quelqu'un qui n'est pas qui n'est jamais
serein et qui est quand même un bon
gouvernant un très bon chef
un chef militaire et c'est aussi un
quelqu'un qui a une vision
administrative ce qui fera la force des
rois de france grâce à sa clairvoyance
il à son formidable sens de
l'organisation
il a renforcé les finances royales y'a
pus superposer au réseau administratif
et aux dalles un réseau administratif
d'état qui s'appuie sur le développement
des écrits face aux traditions orales
c'est tout le symbolisme du sacré de
l'hommage qui se concrétise sur le
papier le capétiens représente la
puissance publique
il est maintenant le sommet d'une
pyramide que seule la base pourra
renverser
philippe auguste meurt le 14 juillet 12
123 après 43 ans de rennes
aliénor repose dans l'abbatiale de
fontevraud avec henry et richard sont
gisant la représente un livre à la main
le xiième siècle est un siècle de
renaissance
il voit renaître le thème de l'amour
face à l'amour de dieu
aliénor en est l'incarnation le fait
qu'elle s'est contrainte à ne pas subir
son destin personne ne lui pardonnera
pas même les historiens du 19e siècle
qui prolongeront la vision machiste
d'une aliénor légère et frivole alors
aliénor d'aquitaine on le sait on a
écrit des tas de livres même des romans
sur aliénor d'aquitaine et d'une femme
exquise très belle ravissante mais
ambitieuse intelligente cupide avides
sensuelle
enfin elle a tout pour plaire c'est
pourtant ce même 19e siècle qui
ressentiraient le besoin de réunir
officiellement héloïse et abélard au
cimetière du père lachaise
c'est par sa légion de noir qu'aliénor
rentrer dans les livres d'histoire dans
lesquelles le rôle capital de philippe
auguste a été longtemps trop peu
souligné il répond pourtant à la
problématique qu'aliénor avait eu le
mérite de soulever en créant un
déséquilibre culturelle et politique
philippe canalise les passions autour de
la patrie et l'amour de celle ci il est
le dernier roi être sacré du vivant de
son père sans philippe saint louis son
petit fils n'aurait sans doute pas pu
rentrer de la manière dont il est rentré
dans ces mêmes livres d'histoire